the rehabilitation of the DC extended
universe continues with birds of prey
and the fantabulous emancipation of one
Harley Quinn the movie has screened for
critics and early viewers are taking to
social media to heap praise on the
Margot Robbie lead film this is what
they're saying
joining Harley and a quest to bring the
pain to Ewan McGregor's black masks are
a pair of kick-ass anti-heroes a Gotham
City cop and one scrappy kid jurnee
smollett Bell portrays Black Canary
while Mary Elizabeth Winstead holds down
the role of Huntress they are flanked by
rosey Perez's detective Renee Montoya
and Cassandra King a youngster who has
incurred the black mask's rap
played by Ellijay Bosco critics near
unanimously a find that this cast as
they say freaking killed it Courtney
Howard of fresh fiction tweeted
delightfully devilish and deliriously
wicked this irreverent rule-breaking
riot delivers a contact I Cathy Yin is a
genius
Robbie Smollett Winstead Perez and Vasco
are perfection some critics disagreed
amongst themselves not about whether or
not the cast aced it but rather around
the question of who aced it the hardest
Angie Hahn of Mashable tweeted that
Winstead's
Huntress is the movies clear MVP while
fansite its Kristen Lopez opined that
Smollett Bell's Black Canary was on the
contrary the movies real show stealer
what you are so cool Yolanda Machado of
The Wrap
meanwhile refused to take sides she
tweeted it's truly an ensemble with
every woman bringing it
Christina Hudson's script was lively
funny and everything I've been waiting
for in the DC EU Kathy Yin created a
Gotham that I can't wait to revisit
chemistry among the cast is great but
birds of prey is a superhero movie and
critics also agreed that it delivers the
action-packed goods with some of the
craziest most visceral fight scenes ever
put to film you heard that right
yan and company have apparently created
a true action showcase the likes of
which the DC films had not yet seen less
do you think we're being hyperbolic
here's what Rosie Knight of IGN has to
say
she wrote damn birds of prey delivers
its
glittery hard action comedy that has the
best choreographed fight scenes I've
seen in a superhero movie
it also features my fav comic book film
needle drop ever her colleague Laura
Prudhomme agreed she tweeted
birds-of-prey is a brian losing with
attitude and some of the most inventive
bone-crunching fight sequences in the
superhero genre to date I went in with
low expectations and was pleasantly
surprised by how much fun I had it
doesn't reinvent the wheel but has style
despair Jill pantos II of io9 called the
fight scenes phenomenon and cinema
blends Sean O'Connell echoed this
sentiment admitting birds-of-prey
is worth seeing for the kick-ass action
and the funhouse fight scene alone the
trailers for birds of prey give every
indication that McGregor would give an
unhinged gleefully scenery-chewing
performances black mask and were happy
to report that this indeed appears to be
the case well you know ways lustre
you're just a silly little girl with no
one around to protect her in fact we'd
go so far as to say that early reactions
indicate that we might just be looking
at the best villainous performances in a
DC EU movie today griffin Schiller of
the playlist tweeted could not get
enough of McGregor's black mask
hysterical eccentric and deliciously
pathetic a rock and kick-ass good time
comic books Brandon Davis called
McGregor's performance sinister and
hilarious
while veteran film critic Katie Walsh
simply tweeted for your consideration
Ewan McGregor Best Supporting Actor
McGregor did have a bit of competition
however from Chris Messina who portrayed
the black mask's psychopathic sidekick
Victor Zsasz Angie Hahn tweeted would
you like to send a little prayer of
thanks for the costume makeup and hair
people responsible for Christmas Cena's
entire situation here because Wow yes
thank you
of course some reviewers jumped online
to point out some of the flicks faults
some critics felt that the flick worked
better as a Harley Quinn solo vehicle
others had minor issues of the pacing or
the plot for instance Jermaine Lussier
of io9 tweeted birds-of-prey is solid
the unpredictable structure keeps the
first-half moving and the action boosts
the rest
Robbie is excellent as is McGregor its
tamer than expected and the basic story
can get lost in the complex setups but
it were
more often than not yes this is pretty
much the closest any critic came to a
negative assessment all in all the flick
was heralded as one of DC's best thanks
in large part to Yan and Hudson who have
apparently crafted something pretty
special the DC extended universe may
have gotten off to a rocky start but it
looks like the franchise has finally hit
its stride thanks to more universally
well-received flicks like Aquaman and
Shazam placing an emphasis on solid
standalone movies made by gifted
committed filmmakers has paid off go
figure
and some critics went so far as to place
birds at or near the top of the DCE you
pack Mike Russo of GameSpot tweeted I'm
happy to report that birds of prey is my
favorite modern DC movie yet like Shazam
it carves its own path with totally
unique aesthetic action and tone Margot
Ewan and all the rest are 100%
fantabulous Mashable's Alison Foreman
called the flick quote leagues better
than Suicide Squad and opined that this
was quote in large part because we get a
rare glimpse into the rich inner life of
the female super villain and it actually
delivers on what was promised in the
trailer
discussing films Ben Roth summed up the
consensus with his team he wrote birds
of prey is a stylishly fantastic ride
Margot Robbie is in top form Harley has
never been quirkier and more loveable
well-made shot wood beautiful colour and
overall a sleek piece of grand
entertainment also McGregor is the best
we need more birds of prey it's great
ladies and gentlemen we have a lot to
look forward to birds of prey and the
fantabulous Emancipation of one harley
quinn hits the big screen on February
7th 2020 check out one of our newest
videos right here Plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies and TV
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]
you